alright well here's another star who has
something new cookin Judith Carter and
we have your first look first for sweet
potato pudding you need sweet potatoes
only et can show you Jennifer mixing up
her grandma's sweet potato recipe and
our home kitchen my grandmother just
says nutmeg allspice cinnamon just to
taste so I don't know we just have to
wing it sometimes I do something called
pretend cooking show on my Instagram and
of your Instagram so I know all about
pretend cooking show on her pretend
series we love our dishes like fish
sticks
oh but making our sweet potato dishes
for her idol Ina Garten Barefoot
Contessa cooked like a pro Thanksgiving
special so I did a pretend cooking show
it's like we just did it yeah we did it
the way we normally do my assistant
knife the two previously shot an episode
together at Jen's house picking veggies
from the garden and grilling up
swordfish gentle though she's absolutely
starstruck by the legendary cook
Barefoot Contessa yeah so this time
we're rushing right out to buy some
sweet potatoes it's gonna be fun her TV
show so you can that's that's my big
Thanksgiving
[Music]